welcome to frat it's time for me to
review your submissions
i asked you to photoshop these pictures
now i'm going to review them
and for next week we got a new topic if
you're a musician
it's time to to get your music galley on
i'm gonna add a bunch of uh audios
you can sample it whatever way you want
just make make a
song make a jamming song if you got that
beat
let it flow okay
let's go let's let's review this [ __ ]
well it said it was for free so i mean
i'll take it
good photoshop extremely attractive i
don't know what else to say really
okay sure whatever good job good job
good job for [ __ ] sake what's with the
content joke
i have plenty of content
[ __ ] jesus if if
if i didn't have any content then
explain why i'm hunting
myself okay explain that flawed logic
you can't argue with facts you the
people of your eye can expand over 45
when you see something that you love
well this is just science again stop
stop this oh it's so cute with edgar
though
what
that's kind of awesome i don't know why
you didn't make the center point
but whatever it's cool i appreciate it
i'd buy it whoa what is that
that's pretty cool beauty loop
that's creative that's pretty [ __ ]
cool well done
well done um great name by the way
i'm punk so i must rebel i'm asian
so i must like math i dye my hair crazy
colors
so i must be looking for
i'm the biggest channel on youtube so i
must make billions of millions
billions and millions is the shittiest
meme i've ever seen and for some reason
you guys keep posting
pewdiepie good suck blonde swedish man
get suck
okay all right great great appreciate uh
pornhub
hitting me up though with the with the
vip account
i mean nothing nothing happened cocaine
marijuana
every day bro respecting women bro
now that's just sexy i think i did a
thumbnail like this once but that's uh
that's pretty good i would eat it
i would uh rub it on my body
wow it looks so real i i almost can't
tell that this isn't
i remember it though that one time me
and fake martial had a child together
do you think god stays in heaven because
he is afraid of
i don't photoshop brad okay he hasn't
deserved it
[ __ ] this this is the worst me thank you
for
making not you quality
thank you thank you i have the nicest
viewers
on youtube you guys are too kind what
have i done to deserve such a wonderful
audience
that truly appreciates me what are you
[ __ ] gay
all right well this video is done thank
you guys so much
uh i got a i got a i got a
dentist appointment
[Music]
that was a joke i'm still here
nothing like a good old respecting women
meme god damn it
it's not true by the way if it was
myself there
then we can talk pewdiepie is not
original
what no jack's films copied me
everyone knows that he's ripping off my
whole
formula my whole thing i did yai way
before jack's films guys
oh ain't you the cutest little thing is
math related to science
oh no it's oh katy perry
what happened where can i find myself a
relationship
like oh okay yeah no it's another brat
we do look very cute in that picture not
gonna lie we do look
way cuter in that picture than any of
these other ones
wow that's [ __ ] awesome
hell yeah i i always wanted to eat
jack oh man that's really cool
fair enough fair enough well played well
played see even if you're [ __ ]
you can still make it you can still make
it there is hope for everyone did i
spend too much time on this
yes do i regret it yet no it's [ __ ]
awesome
hell yeah well done i love it
i look like uh i like the edgar in the
background as well
all right we're going to the final page
so these best
be good okay [ __ ] maybe i should do a
fan art competition because these are
[ __ ] awesome
very cool very nice yakima um
absolutely beautiful
the anatomy of this uh ramen
is uh flawless oh god what the [ __ ] is
this
no just know okay just know
sweden is my city are you religious
me the book of
what can i say the pugs awakened
i just saw edgar so cute marcia looks
amazingly disfigured well done uh really
you really hit the nail on that one
the pugs awakens okay
all right goddammit
keep respect but he also
[Music]
well done that was good i like that one
whoa
that's [ __ ] awesome jesus christ
that's terrifying
why am i so turned on right now
excuse me i have to do something oh
just kidding i'm still here that's
[ __ ] awesome well done gwen
i am pregnant
you're [ __ ]
but this is in photoshop yes it is okay
don't believe the lies
of the media or the reddit comments
cocaine marijuana be
disrespected of course it had to make it
back again
pewds get wrecked at sgdq i would really
prefer
if you stop
[Music]
well done well use of the shitty source
material that i gave you guys
okay no that is wrong
that is factually incorrect
peter should be 720 he never yeah that's
true i still have shitty internet
this person tried to
i i nothing to fear that's how you know
your phone is
safe for [ __ ] sake
[Applause]
seriously
that should have been the thumbnail of
that video god damn it alright so the
the last one the top one goes to massive
weeb youtube
nice touch in the back ah come on what's
her name
of course uh excuse me my name is
pewdiepie all right
i'm a little offended that you
misgendered me
okay that was it for this week's
honestly i love these i think these are
my favorite weekly videos to do
i know everyone's like oh he's out of
ideas
because he asked his fans but i think
it's cool i think it's fun and
i don't know it's not that great
actually i think about it
it's the same [ __ ] over and over
basically
but if you think you have the skills for
next week
to make it in the video
check out the link in the description
make the most lit song possible
and you will make it to the next level
my name is pewdiepie and this has been
bro
awesome that was so cringe i don't know
why i was going with that
sister fister
[Music]
you